tu regardes ton frère ton frère
s'est fait tirer dessus j'ai l'impression que c'est mon
devoir de te chercher de la bière c'est
ce que je veux faire dit-elle comme un grand
frère
tu n'es jamais ma grande courbe probable d'
accord nous nous sentons un peu  Je vois beaucoup d'hommes,
tu es un œuf mort, essayant de t'aider
J'aime l'équipe de
saut  ouais comme - doux
coup de nigga
[Musique]
ouais mes frères juste comme s'il a été
tué aussi
Je ne sais pas comment je vais utiliser le plan C
ce qui s'applique il disparaît là-bas est-ce que
nous avons de la belle
parce que la station
[Musique] est
dystopique  arbre coller des médicaments aux gens à
chaque fois stupide stupide stupide 250 250